PRESENTER: I'd like to
introduce Jill Ebstein.
She's a personal friend.
And she's a writer, but writing
is not really her day job.
She's worked for lots
of large corporations,
like HP and Citicorp and some
biotech startups in the area.
And she does business
consulting and marketing.
But she likes to deal with
the human side of things
and interact with people.
And that's what really
led her to write this book
or compile this book.
And she's got another book
already out and another one
on the way that she's
working on or thinking about.
So without further
ado, Jill Epstein.
JILL EBSTEIN: I love that.
Nice, short, and to the point.
I'm so glad to be here.
Jason, thank you
for bringing me.
And I want this to
be a conversation,
a two-way conversation,
not just a one-way thing.
And I think I want to
start by describing what
led me to do this at my pace.
As you see, this book is all
about blue sky and open roads.
And I did this
because at the time,
Sheryl Sandberg's book
had come out on "Lean In."
And as most of you
remember, "Lean In,"
it was sort of-- you
can belly up to the bar,
and you can get a
lot further if you're
completely invested
and determined
and willing to raise your hand.
And so it was actually a great
message for a lot of-- it
was really written for women,
and a lot of women loved it.
And a lot of women
felt marginalized and
disenfranchised from
the whole thing,
and there was no book
that seemed to capture
the way they were doing life.
And I got a little
tired of hearing
a lot of the judgmentalism
between the women
were what I call
on the autobahn,
going full speed ahead
in a linear fashion,
and the ones who were on the
winding road with the stops
and the starts and the
u-turns and the forks
in the road, ones who
were venturing in a much
different kind of pace.
And I really
believe that we have
to try hard to reserve judgment
and to basically find our way
and let other people
find their way.
And so in the spirit of
trying to help create
a voice for those women
who felt marginalized
with the "Lean In" conversation,
I wanted their stories.
And I looked around, and
I couldn't find that book.
And so I decided, well, we
need to capture those stories.
And when my kids
were in high school,
there was a series
called "This I Believe."
It was 500-word pieces.
I don't know if
anybody knows about it.
But it was very pithy.
It captured a moment, a belief.
And I thought, well,
you really couldn't
tell a journey in any real way
of any interest in 500 words.
But what if I did 1,000 words?
Could I capture my
story in 1,000 words?
So I wrote my story.
Then I assembled some good
friends into my house.
And I said, I want you to
read this piece that I wrote.
Don't pay any attention to me.
I'm just going to be
working on the side
while you read my piece.
Which of course, was not true.
I was totally staring
at them the whole time,
seeing were they absorbed.
Were their eyes wandering
off different places?
And I knew I had
a loser, actually,
at that one, because they
weren't really absorbed.
And then I actually
interviewed them,
which is what I
do in my day job,
is I interview and
get market feedback.
And I learned some of
the gotchas for me.
And so then I rewrote
my piece completely.
And then I came up with the
idea of guidelines, which now
drives every "At My Pace" book.
And so I came up
with the guidelines.
I wrote my piece.
I sent it back to my friends.
And they were like,
oh, this is awesome.
I got such positive
feedback, and I
knew they weren't doing it to be
nice, because I saw the first.
Round
So then I got the message out.
I did two things simultaneously.
One is I got the message out to
friends of friends of friends,
because I wanted a big circle.
And I said I want people
to tell their stories.
I have guidelines.
I will help them.
And so I was getting
the message out.
And the second thing
I was looking at
is how am I going to
actually deliver a book?
Can I find an agent?
So I went to four
different agents
that were recommended to
me with my connections.
And all four agents
independently
said the same thing--
will this be about
some famous people?
I said, no.
This is about people
like you and me--
good, ordinary,
everyday people trying
to construct a life
and a journey that
has meaning, to which they
said-- each one of them
independently-- that
is a great idea,
but I can never sell
this to a publisher.
It needs famous.
So I felt that was clear.
And so then I decided
I would self-publish,
which I like that
anyway, because I
get to be in the
driver's seat, and I
get to own the pace
myself of how we do this.
So I then proceeded to
start to collect pieces.
And so the first piece and the
36th piece, I think, in a way
that I could never
have predicted,
as bookend pieces
totally tell the story
and the goal about my pace.
The first piece was called
"Discovering My Way,"
and it's by a woman
named Fran Heller.
I don't read too
much on these things,
but I read a little bit, just so
you can get it in their words.
And Fran's story
is the following.
She grew up as a daughter
of an academician.
And during his
sabbatical, she would
go to Spanish-speaking
countries,
and she learned to
speak Spanish fluently.
And she learned how to
acculturate and really
take on the environment
she was living in.
And she remembers
being five years old
and saying to her parents--
she heard Sargent Shriver
announced the Peace Corps,
and saying, I want to do the
Peace Corps when I get older.
She remembered-- at five.
So then she grows,
and she does life.
She joins.
She has a job at the ACLU.
She has a job at a
publishing house.
She gets married.
They go do the Peace Corps.
And then she comes back.
They have kids.
And when they have kids, she
feels like her priorities
change a little bit.
At least how she wants to do
life changes a little bit.
She doesn't want
to go back to work.
She wants to be at home.
She wants to be with
other like moms.
At the time, it was
moms in her area
that were doing the same thing.
She did that for a while.
And then she realized she really
needed to go back to work.
So she becomes a travel agent.
She starts her
own travel agency.
So she has the freedom to
be able to come and go, make
some money, run a business,
but be with her kids
if she wants to.
And then her daughter is
diagnosed with cancer.
And the next thing she knows,
she's at the hospital 24/7,
helping with her daughter
and with her laptop
doing her business.
And she's with all
these Latino families
who don't speak the
language as well
and are trying to navigate a
very complicated health care
system.
And there she is, taking
care of her daughter,
and also reaching out and
helping these families.
Her daughter passes.
Her marriage dissolves.
And now she's trying to figure
out what does she do next.
And it turns out that
one of her clients,
when she was doing
a travel brokerage,
was a Wall Street firm that
traded in energy credits.
And at the time she was
servicing his travel needs,
she said, you have an
opportunity, I think,
in the retail market.
Have you ever tried
the retail market?
But it wasn't something in
his bandwidth at the time.
And so when she's figuring
out what to do next,
he says to her, well,
you have this idea.
Why don't you come
work for us and see
if you can make this
retail segment go?
So she thought,
well, what the heck.
She is the kind of
person who will always
go stretch herself and
try something different.
And she does that for two years.
And for two years, she's
on the trading floor,
which she describes
as a noisy frat house.
And after two years, she
decides it's really not her.
She doesn't know what is her,
but she knows that's not her.
And then through
serendipity, she
has coffee with an
acquaintance who turns out
to be a social worker.
And the social worker describes
her position, what she does.
And friends says, ah, that's it.
That took her back to that
moment in the hospital
when she was helping
people navigate the system,
and she loved being
a help and a support.
And so I will now read from
the book what she writes.
"At the ripe age of 44, I
enrolled in grad school.
I was one of the oldest in the
group and considered every day
an opportunity, no
matter the workload.
My first day was
on 9/11, and I was
at my internship at a senior
center in Washington Heights.
There were many Latinos
in the room with me
glued to the TV, some of
them political refugees that
had fled to the US as
their ultimate safe haven.
Their doubt and
anxiety were palpable.
I was in the right
place for me."
That was the very first
piece I worked on,
"Discovering My Way."
And it was very
validating for me.
Here was a woman-- a really,
truly wonderful woman--
who had to weather
pain, had to weather
the complexities of life,
who ended up in her 40s
finding her calling.
I was in New York
in the last year,
and I actually met
her face to face,
because most of my conversations
happened on the phone.
And she just loves
what she does.
She is in Columbia.
She started a
palliative care program,
which was also hearkened back to
her daughter and her treatment
with cancer.
And so I thought, wow.
This is great.
This is motivating to me to
know that I have something
here that I can work with.
So then I proceeded to
send out my guidelines
and capture stories.
And it took about a
year, a year and a half.
And then I think I'm all done.
I'm having lunch at my
daughter's in Manhattan
in New York.
And my niece is there.
And I say to my daughter,
Sarah, this is awesome--
35 pieces.
I'm ready to publish.
And my niece, who's in her
mid-thirties, says to me,
do you have that voice,
that woman who is single,
who never got
married, who never had
kids, who always felt that she
let her family down because she
didn't meet their expectations?
I said, Hillary, I
have single women.
Not everyone has kids.
But maybe I don't
have that voice.
Do you want to write that piece?
And she did.
And that piece is the piece
that-- when I tell you
this book has been reviewed
by so many people--
that piece always
captures people's
hearts and their attention.
Because Hillary is so
talented and so wonderful
in so many ways, and she should
never have any self-doubt.
There should never be any
of that feeling of why am I
not measuring up to other
people's expectations, whatever
those are.
And yet she had them.
And so she decides
one day while she's
watching the
marathon, the New York
marathon-- she
says to her friend,
we're going to run the marathon.
And her friend is
a little surprised.
And she says, why are we
going to run the marathon?
Because it will be the first
true choice of something
that I did for me that was
never expected by anybody else.
I want to run the marathon.
Hillary is a large woman,
and she doesn't like to run.
But somehow, this challenge took
on such significance to her.
And she trained
for a whole year.
I would ask her how is it going.
And besides the
sores and the aches
and the need for a
massage, she would say,
I'm so sick of Beyonce.
I've been listening to so
much Beyonce when I run.
I've got to find somebody else.
So then that year was the year
that Hurricane Sandy happened.
And so after all that
training for a year,
the marathon was canceled.
She was devastated.
I really-- the most
serious mourning and loss
that I've seen in a long time.
And I understood it in a
way that I couldn't possibly
have understood had I not
understood this piece.
And then she signed
up to do it again,
and the next year, she runs.
And she describes at
the end of her story
what it meant to her to see
all these people lining up.
Because she had friends.
My daughter was there.
She had a lot of people lining
up to support her in this run.
And she said their presence
not only provided strength
and encouragement
along the route,
but it was an affirmation of me
and my choices, a celebration
that even if my life doesn't
follow the predictable path,
I am worthy of being celebrated
for the choices I do make
and all their iterations.
And the question I
asked myself when
I was looking at
all these pieces
is-- the first piece was
about discovering my way.
The last piece was about
celebrating my choices.
How do we go from
discovery to celebration?
What's that process
that gets us there?
So I will share with you
what I call the new three
R's that I learned.
But before I do
that, I want to know,
does anybody have any questions,
any thoughts so far in anything
that I've said?
Anything you want to say?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm interested in
how you collected the stories--
if you were looking
for certain voices
and would go and seek
them out, or if you
would spread the word throughout
your network, and people self--
signed up for it?
how did you navigate that?
JILL EBSTEIN: Well,
that's a great question.
It was both.
I definitely had
a push going on.
And I went to so
many different--
you think all the places in
your world that you've been,
and I would go into
those places and say,
does anybody here
want to write a story?
Do you know anybody who
wants to write a story?
But what I didn't want--
I'm in my late 50s.
I'm Jewish.
I live in Newton.
I'm privileged.
I did not want 36 people
that were like me.
If I were to grade myself
on that particular score,
I would give myself
a B or B minus.
I tried very hard.
But a lot of people are
uncomfortable telling
their story.
And actually, when
you deal with what
I call ordinary people, people
like you and me, most people
either, A, don't feel they
have a story worth telling--
I have to convince them that
they have a great story.
I'll tell you an example
of that in a second.
And then some people just
think they don't write.
A lot of people are not
comfortable writing.
And to that, I always say,
but I am your safety net,
because I love to write.
And I can help you even
capture your voice.
I spend a lot of time
working on these pieces
with the contributors.
So I take those away.
Now, the second book, which
I'll do a plug for later,
called "Lessons From My
Mother--" it looks like this--
I did a much better
job on capturing
a much broader audience.
Well, first of all,
it's men and women.
But it also-- it's across
geographies, ethnicities.
But that's a good question.
And it's something that I feel--
and I actually acknowledge
that right in front.
I say, I didn't do a great
job on that when I tried.
But you can't make
people tell a story who
don't want to tell your story.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JILL EBSTEIN: Any other
questions before I move on?
OK.
So how we get from
discovering my way
to celebrating my choices?
I think there's a new three
R's that we need to embrace.
And the first one is resilience.
Now, we see resilience written
up in stories all the time.
But when you hear
these stories, and you
see the moments of challenge
and struggle and the strength
that it takes for
people to persevere,
it gave, for me,
resilience a new meaning.
So I had a colleague of mine
from my HP days who said to me,
you need to call my--
first email my sister.
And then if she
doesn't email you back,
you need to call my sister,
because she has a great story.
And I find out a little
bit about her story,
but not enough to do much.
So I email.
Susana Fonticoba is her name.
And nothing back.
I email her again.
And then I email her.
I say, your sister, Jeanie,
says I must talk to you.
You have a great story.
And here's what
I'm trying to do.
So she calls me back and
she says, I have no story.
I said, well, Jeanie
says you have a story.
Tell me a little
bit about yourself.
There's not that much to tell.
OK.
I was widowed at 40.
I lost my job.
I had to raise two kids.
I had to start a business.
And yes, I got through it.
But what's the story there?
I'm like, that's a story.
So what happened-- her story
is so poignant and so--
when I first read
it, I literally--
I'm not a crier or a
teary kind of person,
and I hate mushy gushy.
But her story really
did get to me.
She remembers taking a
chairlift up Cascade Mountain.
And they get to the
top of the mountain.
And She's in her 20s.
It's beautiful.
And they decide it's
such a beautiful day,
they'll just walk
down, it's so pretty.
Of course, they don't
realize how far the walk is.
And they're walking and
walking and walking.
And it looks like
they've gotten nowhere.
And so she sits down,
and she pouts on a rock.
She sits down on a
rock and just pouts.
And her husband says to
her at the time, get up.
You can't pout.
Nobody is going to rescue you.
Nobody is going to be here.
We have to get ourselves
down the mountain.
And he's thinking about
sunset, how far it is, what
the pace is they have to keep.
So they get down before sunset.
All is good.
And when he's 42,
she's 40, he just
dies of a sudden heart attack.
She has two young kids.
I think they're,
like, 10 and 12.
And she's working
at AT&T. And shortly
thereafter, she's laid off.
So they don't have much money.
She is doing this--
she's mourning the loss.
But she finds comfort
in her widow friends.
They're the ones who
understand her loss.
But her widow friends
are much older than her.
There aren't too many
40-year-old widows.
And AOL has just hit this world.
And they have computers,
and they do not
know how to make AOL
work on their computer.
So she's like, this is great.
She helps them with
AOL on their computer.
And in exchange, she gets
this companionship and support
system that she
desperately needs.
So her friends--
they appreciate her.
They also understand
what she's going through.
And so one of her
friends says to her,
basically, she should start
a business doing this.
She says-- this is
what she describes.
She says with no help,
with no job, and no spouse,
I helped my friends learn
their way around AOL
to keep my sanity.
One day, one of my
friends suggested
that others like her were also
struggling with their PCs.
And since no one was hiring, I
could simply create my own job.
It's madness, I thought.
I had no experience
being a business owner.
But then I had been
no hiker either.
So she has that image of
going down the mountain,
and she can't pout.
She has to get herself going.
I spread the word.
And soon, I was in
business, coming
to the rescue of many a senior
lost in the world of Windows
and AOL.
While the money was a fraction
of what I used to earn,
my new job was helping me
become a whole person again.
Along the hike down my own
personal Wildcat Mountain,
life changed in many ways.
I became business-savvy
and gained confidence
I never would have foreseen.
I joined a professional
organization.
I was soon on its
leadership team,
and then I became president.
And all the while, I was
developing my business.
Over the years, I had to
stand strong and survive
many major events
without my husband--
graduations, walking my
daughter down the aisle,
the girls moving out as adults.
And she finished and
she said, I started out
as a shy wife of a man
who was bigger than life.
If the young woman in her 20s
could meet this mid-50s woman,
she would be
completely astonished.
The funny thing about
that piece to me--
I always felt like, wow, the
growth and the resilience.
But I went-- my mother,
who recently passed--
I'd go visit her a lot.
She lived in Denver.
And the facility
that she was at,
I would get a people
group of people together.
I'd start talking
about these stories.
And you just want to
keep them engaged.
And whenever I read that
piece, they were like, well,
we could update that.
If the 50-year-old in us could
meet the 80-year-old in us,
they would be
completely astonished.
You can look ahead
and see the growth.
So that's a great
example of resilience.
And that one was poignant
and has some very sad moments
in it.
But also, you felt very
good about where she got.
But there's others
that are just funny.
There's a piece in
here by Sandra Gregory
called "A Few Minor Repairs."
And she and her husband,
they ride the dot com boom,
and they have all the houses,
and they have the cars.
They're leading a big life.
And then the bust happens, and
then they lose their wealth.
And eventually, they
lose their marriage.
They have a little bit of--
I think maybe she would call it
some combination of stupidity
and a massive ego.
They decided to open up an auto
repair shop for fancy cars,
because they drive fancy cars.
So they'll take their last
dollars that they have
and make that work,
and it doesn't work.
And the next thing you
know, she is sleeping--
their marriage is dissolved.
She is sleeping in the
basement of her brother's
house on a Little Mermaid bed
while her kids are upstairs.
And she talks about what
she's going to do next.
And she also lands on her feet.
So there's a lot of
stories of resilience.
So that's the first R,
which is resilience.
The next R is reinvention.
But I feel like reinvention is
a very big word, and most of us
don't really know
what to do with it.
It sounds like such
an overwhelming thing
to do to suddenly remake
yourself into something else.
So I call it-- there was a
woman who wrote a piece here,
Donna Surges Tatum, and she
talks about taking a left turn,
doing that occasional
thing, that change-up
that takes you out of your
ordinary comfortable zone.
And I feel like that's a lot
more realistic about what
we can sign up for sometimes.
And I would say that
for me, "At My Pace"
is a reinvention story
for me, because I never
thought of myself as
publishing books and speaking.
When I speak, I usually speak
about market research findings.
I don't speak about
things like this.
So it was helpful for
me to actually see
that this is something that
people do in smaller ways.
So there's a bunch of
pieces on reinvention
that I think are a lot of fun.
But there's one called
"Finding My Passion After 50,"
by Rhonda Benjamin.
And she's a lawyer,
a real estate lawyer.
She did law for decades.
She raised her kids and
did law, and she hated it.
She hated reading the contracts.
She hated all the bickering and
the contentiousness of it all.
And she would fantasize
about things she
could do that would not be law.
And then one night,
she goes out to dinner
with her husband and her
son and her son's girlfriend
and their parents, her parents.
And the girlfriend's parents are
just a total nightmare to her.
She comes back so
undone and so--
she does not know what to
do with her restless angst
about this dinner.
She felt they were horrible
in many different ways.
And so she tries to go to sleep,
but she can't go to sleep.
So in the middle of the
night, she wakes up.
She's [INAUDIBLE], but
she gets out of bed.
And she writes the story of
her dinner and the conversation
and the peculiarities of it all.
And she is laughing the
whole time she writes.
And all of a
sudden, she realizes
not just that it's
therapeutic for her,
but that she always had this
voice in writing that she's
never really expressed.
And she's fortunate.
Not everybody can do this.
But she was able to
give up her law job.
And she started a magazine
called "Better After 50."
And so it just ended
up becoming complete.
That's not a right
turn or a left turn.
That's just a whole
other road entirely.
But you see there is another
story by Melissa Ludtke.
She is a Neiman Fellow.
You guys know what
Neiman Fellows are?
It's a designation for
very talented journalists
who get these scholarships.
And she writes about being 40,
thinking she would be a mom,
but she wasn't a mom.
And so she goes to
China, and she ends up
adopting a baby girl.
And she has now made
her life understanding
the Chinese culture.
And she has a bunch
of writing and stuff
that revolves around that.
But in her early years, she
was a sports journalist.
And so she talks
about-- actually,
there was a great quote in
Melissa's piece about what she
did and what it meant to her.
And I just-- it
really reminds me
that there's so much more that
we can do that's in our range.
You don't have to
actually go to China
and adopt a daughter to see
that, wow, I can reinvent.
But here she talks about "At
two junctures, one recent
and the other nearly
two decades ago,
I stepped off my usual
path to head towards places
neither customary ambition
nor conventional wisdom
would suggest.
The earlier detour
brought me to motherhood,
and the other one at the age
of 46 when I had no job."
Now she's working on
bringing her message out.
So I want to stop
here and ask you
whether reinvention
or taking a left turn
is something you think about
in your own personal lives.
Does it feel
comfortable for you?
Is it scary to you?
When you think about that,
what's your overriding emotion?
Anybody have an example
of a small moment
that they've taken a turn?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I can share one.
It happened probably
10 years ago.
So I had moved to Boston, and
I didn't know anyone here.
I was with my husband, who
got into a graduate program.
And I started to
work at a company
that I had worked with before,
but with all new people.
And I was having a hard
time settling into the city
and making friends.
So I started to go to a fitness
studio and take classes there.
And I have no dance background,
no athletic background.
But I decided I wanted to teach.
And so I went through a
six-month training program
for--
over a course of 250 hours
back and forth to New York
to learn to teach
this barre class.
And it's been something I've
done for the past 10 years.
And so it's totally different
to my full-time role
here at Google, and
it made no sense.
But I really-- it was one of
the hardest things I ever did,
and I'm so glad I did it.
JILL EBSTEIN: Yeah.
That's awesome.
I remember getting on a
tennis court when I was 38.
I played tennis a lot.
And thinking, oh
my god, you're just
starting a tennis game at 38.
No way.
That was the scariest moment.
I have done so many
things in my life
that were nowhere near as scary
as getting on the tennis court.
And now I'm 59, and I
play tennis all the time,
and I'm on a tennis team.
So when you look back at
those moments, you can say,
wow, I was able to
overcome my fear.
And not only that, but
it's such a great balance
to the other things in our life.
Does it ever feel to you-- when
you think about reinvention,
does that feel like
a big word to you,
or does it just feel big to me?
How many people
think-- hands up if you
think it feels like a big word.
I think it's scary.
It's not so easy to
actually envision that.
And this helped me to see
some of the small things
that people do along the way.
It's not wholesale change.
It's incremental
change that people
do to be able to add a
little bit of a change
up, a little freshness
in their lives.
So that's reinvention.
And the third R-- so
the R, resilience.
I'm sorry.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious about
reinvention and whether
or not, in your
stories, or the stories
that you've acquired or
whatnot, if it's always forced.
It sounds like a
lot of times, it's
forced based on circumstances--
or if there is a conscious
choice because of want.
JILL EBSTEIN: That's
a great question.
There are some
times it's forced,
but there are plenty of
times that it's want.
What I will say is that for
some of the reinvention stories,
these are examples of
people who could do it.
In other words, they had
enough of the safety net.
They could go take
a flyer out there.
And for some of
us, that would not
be something that we could do.
I only can do this book
and all these other books
because I have a day job.
If this were the
thing that I needed
to do to send my
kids to college,
it definitely would not work.
But there are plenty
of people out there--
the book starts out with
a woman named Kim Lorusso,
and it's called "Falling
Off the Corporate Ladder."
And her life is just
not working anymore.
And I'm going to
describe that in a second
under a different topic.
But she didn't have to do it.
Just the pain was too high for
her to keep everything static
as it was.
Did you want to say something?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] question
which was, in the cases
where it isn't forced, how
do you know when it's time?
And how do you
step outside of who
you are now to recognize
what you might be instead?
JILL EBSTEIN: Yeah.
So that's a great question.
The people-- when I ask them--
so you made this
change-- it was something
that typically persisted
inside them for a long time.
I'll give you the story
of my brother, who's
not in this book.
My brother was a
lawyer on a partnership
track for a prominent law
firm in the Boston area.
And every year, he would
get an application form
from the Jewish Theological
Seminary to be a rabbi.
He did this for five years.
And every year, I would
say, Wesley, you have kids.
You have a good career.
You went to a great law school.
Can't you just go give a sermon
here and there, and let it sit?
Give it up.
That was the practical
person in me.
I wouldn't say that today.
After five years, he
could not say no to it.
It just persisted.
And there are so many
stories like that
where people-- they just
get driven on a need
that they have.
But what I will say
is that actually how
you meet that need might be
more of a tinkering than all
of a sudden lifting
yourself up and trying
something very different.
There is a story
here by a woman,
by Suzanne Offit
on the need to dig.
It's another rabbi story.
But she had no idea she
wanted to be a rabbi.
She didn't think she ever--
that was just nowhere
in her concept of herself.
But she had been reading.
She'd had boys.
She had a bris.
She wanted to read more.
More and more learning took her
more and more a certain way.
And her husband was
like, well, just continue
to learn and enjoy that, but
leave our life as our life is.
But she couldn't.
She was just propelled.
And to the point that she did
go to a rabbinical school.
She's a wonderful rabbi.
She's a chaplain,
and she really tends
to the people who are in the
most physically challenged
states in their life.
And she had to actually
take her family with her
along this journey.
And she talks about that.
She talks about their need
to have therapy, and all
of a sudden, that
their whole world has
been sent in upheaval.
Because now she's dividing
her time in so many ways,
and they're not just
the center of her world.
and she has so
many other things.
And so it's not an easy path.
But the nice thing
in her story is
that they all grew
in the process,
even though there was some pain.
So I don't think-- the answer
is I don't think, in most cases,
I don't see people-- all
of a sudden, they're like,
OK, I was this,
but now I'm that.
I feel like there's a lot
of testing and tinkering.
And the ones who
actually persist usually
persist because they don't
see an option not to.
It's like why I'm thinking
about my third book.
I don't really want to be
thinking about a third book.
I want to just enjoy
these two and do my work.
And yet I know this third
book is about ready to--
I'm ready to get
the guidelines going
and start a process again.
So I think there's something
inside you that just drives you
in a way that you can't explain
and maybe can't even control.
Actually, you know
David Samberg from--
so he wanted to be
a college professor.
He was getting a PhD
in English literature.
He's all about books.
He's always been about
books, but he's a lawyer.
He was the in-house counsel
for ITA that Google acquired.
And he eventually-- they
acquired a bookstore,
Porter Square Books.
But that was always a dream.
And eventually, they get it.
But it was something in them.
That book thing was in him from
the time I knew him in his 20s.
So the last theme I
want to talk about
is resetting your perspective.
And that has so
many pieces to it,
but I'm going to
talk about two today.
One is about the
burdens of perfection.
We live in a time now where--
here's what we expect
from ourselves.
We expect 10,000 steps a
day, an immaculate house,
kids who are-- if you have
kids, the kids are doing well
in school, and they have all
those extra skills and lessons
and stuff, so they're becoming
these big, well-rounded human
beings.
And your career is
on track, and you're
able to communicate
with all the loved ones,
and you have a book
club that everybody is--
you have all these
things that you
think are all going to work.
And of course, that burden
is a big, heavy burden.
And you can burn out
and spin your wheels
trying to make sure that
all those things actually
get achieved.
So I mentioned Kimberly
Lorusso a second ago.
Her story is that she
opens up the book.
She's on a train
headed out of Boston
to go pick up her
kids from day care.
The train has malfunctioned, and
so they're dead on the tracks.
Her husband is traveling.
And so yet again, she's
going to be the last one
to get her kids from daycare.
Yet again, they're going
to end up waiting for her,
because she doesn't think
she'll get there in the hours
that they've posted.
And then she's
going to rush home,
and she's going to go
through the bedtime ritual,
and then she's going
to return to her job
to finish the work that she
didn't finish during the day
because she was rushing
to get the kids.
So she falls off the
corporate ladder.
And what she describes
is she says--
her husband travels, and she
travels some in the community.
Hard to find time.
So she says after my husband and
I finally find a quiet moment
to talk about our
challenging schedules,
three things become clear to me.
First, I need to accept that
in our current scenario,
I can't make everything work
to the standard that I'd like.
I know that I am fortunate to
have a set of problems caused
by the too-full plate of being
a parent, a wife, and a working
professional.
Believe me-- I wouldn't trade
my problems for someone else's.
And yet somehow, I am
not enjoying my bounty.
Everything feels like a
burden, and on particular days,
a Rubik's cube
that I can't solve.
So she goes back to
her employer to see
if there is any
flexibility, because they're
known to be a flexible,
21st-century, modern-day
employer.
And they say, oh, yes, in
many jobs, but not for you.
I'm sorry.
We can't do anything
for you here.
So she ends up leaving.
And it's scary for her,
but she's also helped out,
because her husband
has a job, and also
because she knows
she can actually
leave this with some
consulting gigs in hand.
She can consult for her
employer, her ex-employer
to be.
She can do some
other consulting.
So she can figure how she
can cushion her landing.
She's picked up
some teaching jobs.
She's an adjunct
teacher at Emerson.
So she's made it work.
And she talks about
work-life integration, not
work-life balance.
It's the ability to be able
to make things work together,
everything has a
little bit of a give.
But you don't have-- balance
is the word that maybe we
use, but we don't
really mean, because I
don't think most
of us don't really
feel like we have balance.
So she describes-- she
says the good news is
we're not eating Costco roasted
chicken nearly so often.
But the best thing is-- she
says in my brave, remade world,
I am not as hard on myself.
She has learned that
perfect is not an option,
and if she doesn't try for
perfect, she's a lot happier.
So I then reached out
to my pediatrician.
Now, my pediatrician-- you
talked about how I find people.
What I knew about her is that
she went to medical school
in her late 30s, and she
had training in her 40s.
And we didn't pick her
up as our pediatrician
till her mid-forties.
I'm like, that's a great story.
I don't know what
happened there,
but I know there's
a great story there.
And she did not disappoint.
It was a great story.
She went to Kent College
during the riots.
She walked down
her wedding aisle
pregnant in a time when
people didn't do that.
Her parents barely
talked to her.
She is great.
She has three kids.
So she says, OK, I'm
going to talk to you.
And then she tells me her story
about her parents, her kids,
and everything.
I'm like, oh, my god, but
you're the perfect person.
This is what I'm. thinking.
I don't say it.
And yet, even
behind the perfect--
it's like Oz behind the curtain.
It's just Oz.
Behind the curtain,
it's just another human
being with a different set, but
a similar set of challenges.
So now she's getting
ready to retire.
And I say to her, OK, so
what does it all mean?
What's the point of
what you've learned
in all these years of being
a pediatrician, and a mom,
and a wife, and all that?
And she says-- this is
how she finishes it.
She says, "There have been
many bumps in this journey.
There were so many times I
felt that I was blundering
and making a wreck of things.
But at this moment, I have found
my peace, and I am thankful.
Sometimes, our words
come back at us.
And right now, I am
hearing the advice
I have given first-time
parents in what
I call reality orientation.
There they sit,
exhausted, exhilarated
with overwhelming
love, determined
not to make any parenting
mistakes They never
tell me this, but I see it.
I've been there.
I tell them you are not going to
raise the first perfect human.
Give up now.
No path is perfect.
No decision is beyond question.
And so I counsel--
love well, be strong,
laugh often, be bold,
and don't think too hard.
As I enter retirement,
the same goes for me.
And so I will."
And I felt-- when I
heard those words,
it was like the
exclamation point
on the burdens of
perfection, what
we do to ourselves by
expecting our perfect kids
and our perfect lives.
The last part that I want to
talk about of the three R's--
I want to remind you, the
first R is Resilience.
The second R is Reinvention.
But somehow, we have to
step it down in a way
that we can get our arms
around it and play with it some
so it's not so foreboding.
And the third one is
resetting our perspective.
And we just talked about
the burdens of perfection.
But the next part
about our perspective
is about how we need to
allow ourselves dormancy.
We need to allow ourselves to
be able to be still and have
some downtime so
that we can continue
to do what we want to do.
If we re-think of
dormancy as what
we need to have before a boost
of productivity, it's helpful.
This is actually--
of all the challenges
that I've read and
digested and all
that, this is the
one that I personally
have the most difficulty with.
So I have a very close friend,
and she graduated from Hopkins.
She's super smart
and hardworking.
And she got on that busy
track that everybody
gets on when you
get out of college
and you get your first job.
And she hated it.
She said, I was not meant
to live a hurried life.
So she and her husband
have a daughter.
And she decides she's going
to get off that track.
And she's a fantastic writer,
a poet and a short story
writer, also a tennis player.
That's how our
worlds came together.
So she writes-- she
was writing poetry,
and her father had a stroke.
And then he was in
Florida, and she's here.
She is going back
and forth, visiting
him every couple of weeks.
They couldn't move him.
And this happened
for over two years.
And she could not
write a poem anymore.
Her poetry pen just died.
And for a woman who
loves to write poetry,
that's the thing
that gives her--
that's like the barre
for you or tennis for me.
That's what she does.
It was painful.
And one morning, she wakes up.
And she has this poem in
her head called "Day One."
It's in the book.
It's the day that
the stroke happens,
and she realizes how much
his world has changed, how
much their world has changed.
But she doesn't think
that he realizes it yet.
She then writes 25
poems in the next month.
He actually passed a few days
after "Day One" was written.
She came down to Florida,
because she got that message.
And she just-- all
of a sudden, it
was just a floodgate
that opened up.
Now, that's an extreme case of
dormancy preceding proactivity.
But I think for all
of us, we feel so
compelled to see if we can get
ahead, and do a little more,
and do a little faster.
My to-do lists are
very long, and it
seems like I add more to them
than I take off from them
that it's hard for us.
I actually-- I was at ABC doing
this, and I asked the group,
do they have a hard
time with this.
These are all women.
They were ABC and ESPN, and
they're pretty much drivers.
And they're like, oh, we have
a horrible time with this.
But one of them said, I have
a sister, and she does yoga,
and she just stares at
a wall for 30 minutes.
And that's her-- just
stares at this wall.
And I'm like, oh,
that's awesome.
And another woman said,
I could never do that.
I'd be looking at that wall.
I'd see a dirty spot.
I'd immediately have to go
get up and scrub the wall.
And that would sort of be what
I would probably be like, too.
So I'm wondering, within this
group, do you ever feel like--
do you have a problem
with dormancy, or can
you allow yourself to--
you have a problem
with dormancy.
Do you ever have that
smart voice inside you
that says even if you have
a problem with dormancy,
I've got to do it?
And what do you do for dormant--
what do you do to be dormant?
AUDIENCE: I just
watch "Law and Order."
JILL EBSTEIN: That's a good one.
Anybody else have
any thoughts for how
they like to be dormant, how
they like to refuel themselves?
AUDIENCE: Sleep
for, like, 12 hours.
PRESENTER: Sleep.
Sleep.
Well, we're usually
underslept as a nation,
so that's probably a good one.
When you think about those
challenges that I've put out
there-- reinvention, the
burdens of perfection,
and allowing yourself dormancy--
are those challenges
that speak to you?
AUDIENCE: So I was
just going to speak
about dormancy for a second.
I find that the only
way to be dormant
is to really be on vacation
for a continuous week
and not look at the
corporate email.
And the day before
coming back, it's all--
I have to find out what's
going on before I get there.
But I see people on my team--
it's not me, but
there are people
on the team who have their
vacation balance totally full.
And the corporation says you can
only accumulate so much time.
And they don't take it.
And I don't know how they
manage to not take it,
because I do need that time.
JILL EBSTEIN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: This year,
I finally decided
I was going to take a
vacation and completely detach
[INAUDIBLE].
And so I completely-- it
took me almost two months
to unbury myself.
I will never do it again.
I will check every other night,
or get some sort of rhythm
so I know that I
could push it off
to others that need it
to be or [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I agree.
I feel like in some cases, if
you take a week off or take
two weeks off and you
don't check your email,
you need three weeks to
recover from your vacation.
So that always gets very
taxing, because it almost
seems like taking a vacation
was a burden in itself
if you don't look
at email at least,
or some kind of maneuvering.
JILL EBSTEIN: Well, I think it's
my biggest personal challenge
of all the things.
And my kids tell me that, too.
They're like, can't
you just do nothing?
And it's very hard,
depending on how you're wired
and what your list is like.
And it also comes back
to that passion or drive
you have inside you for things
you want to do, and maybe
the feeling that
nobody else is going
to do those things
that you need to do.
So I have a hard time with that.
But yet I think that
sometimes, we sort of burn out.
So a lot of this is about--
when you look at this cover--
I spent a lot of time working
on the covers of my books
and what it's
going to look like.
I want the open road.
I want blue sky.
I want us to feel like
we have opportunities
to do so many different things
that we're not as constrained
as we feel.
And yet if we expect ourselves
to have the perfect life,
if we expect ourselves to
be busy and productive all
the time, then the road
doesn't look so open.
The sky doesn't look so blue.
And so that's the challenge.
But if you look at
discovery to celebration,
to be able to celebrate,
to have that energy,
to be able to affirm
what you're doing--
those are some of
the pieces that
have to fall into place
for us to get there.
So now I'm going to make my
small little pitch at the end.
So first of all, if
you guys read this,
I would love reviews on Amazon.
That would be very helpful.
Give it whatever you want.
I don't care about the ratings.
I care that it gets
read and people
have real comments on it.
I apologize.
It is all women in
this particular book,
and that was because
I was responding
to the "Lean In" conversation.
But now I'm going to do
my pitch for book number
two, which is men and women.
And this is "Lessons
From Our Mothers."
It's a mother bird and a small
bird, and it's giving a flower.
So it's about gratitude.
Can you see that?
It's about gratitude.
And for some people, that
flower is an olive branch
for complicated relationships.
It's about how they make
their peace with their moms.
But for others, it's about just
genuine ease and appreciation.
And all these books,
all the "At My Pace,"
it's really about trying
to expand our conversation
with people that we care about,
on topics that we care about,
and being able to
take advantage of all
the different perspectives.
Everybody is different,
but yet our pain points
and our challenges, there's a
lot of commonality in there.
And if this book ends up
facilitating conversation
and some understanding,
then I will
have met my personal goals.
Well, thank you all so
much for coming today.
I really appreciate that.
[APPLAUSE]